Soft robotics is a program that we've
been working on in the lab for a little
bit over a year now and what we've done
is to basically
looks to nature for inspiration
specifically organisms
octopi and squid, soft organisms with
the idea that these robots would have
advantages in terms of manipulation,
maneuverability, fabrications, cost, over
the traditional heart robots that most
people are familiar with one of the
remarkable things that they can do
is they can actually change their
color and appearance and they do this
to
signal one another, to blend in with their
environment. We again drew on the
these organisms as inspiration and
decided
that it was actually a pretty
logical evolution to try and include
some of these aspects and our robots. We
think that they could be very useful for
surgeons. We're also interested in the
idea that we can use to display aspect
of our work by being able to change
colors to be bright or even to glow in
the dark that could actually guy our rescue
workers  to a specific location, like a
survivor or something along those lines.